Welcome to 3AB and today Bible Q&A. My
name is J. D Quinn. I'm going to be your
host. I love being the host because I
get to ask the questions, but more
important is I get to hear the answers.
So, as a group, we're all listening to
what each one of you are saying. And I
know that it takes a lot of time to be
able to put all these things together
because these are some deep questions.
And in putting all this stuff together
to distill it down, wow, takes some time
and it takes some effort. So anyway, I
just want to introduce each one of you.
Introduce yourself. Take about 30 45
seconds. Tell us a little bit something
personal about you. Uh, pastor.
>> All right, JD. Good to be here with you,
Shelley and Derell. Pastor James
Rafferty here. I've been married for 36
years to one wife and have two children
and um the director of disciplehip
ministry here at 3ABN.
>> Amen. And uh my name is Derell Thomas
and I work in the production department
in multiple areas and I also uh enjoy uh
worshiping and uh spending time with my
family uh and serving the Lord together.
>> Amen.
>> I'm Shelley Quinn. I've been here since
2002 and uh I'm scissor happy as you can
tell sporting a new hairo. But uh we
just want to thank you for sending in
your questions because it's our
privilege to study it and get the answer
to you hopefully in a balanced way.
>> Amen.
Now, you know, they mentioned that we
got these questions. How do we get those
questions? And I'm going to give you
three avenues how we receive them. If
you're going to send them in by text,
it's 6182283975.
If you're going to email them, that's
biblea
3abn.tv.
And if you want to use Instagram, it's
3ABN
official. So once again, I just want to
start with prayer and then we'll go with
the questions and uh see where it takes
us. Father, as we come together in the
name of Jesus, just thank you, Lord, for
giving us this opportunity to help make
a positive difference in people's lives
by having a closer walk with you. So,
Father, [music] as we answer these
questions, we just ask through the aid
of the Holy Spirit that the right words
will come out. Lord, we love you. We
thank you, and give you all praise and
glory in the name of Jesus. Amen. Amen.
Okay, let's start off by asking the
first question to you, James. Uh, has
the message of the seven thunders in
Revelation been revealed yet? And this
is from Sandra in Alabama.
Great question, Sandra in Alabama. Yes.
If we look in Revelation chapter 10,
we're going to find that the message of
the seven thunders is a message that was
revealed to John on the aisle of Patmos.
The interesting thing is though is that
this message that was revealed to him
was then sealed up. But notice here as
we read the the context of Revelation
chapter 10 that it was then revealed in
another way. So John uh Revelation
chapter 10 John sees an angel a mighty
angel come down from heaven verse one
clothed with a cloud and upon his head
is a rainbow. His face is as it was the
face of the sun and his feet like
pillars of fire. This is very similar to
the description we find in Daniel
chapter 10 of another being that comes
to Daniel and gives him understanding of
prophecies that Daniel had been given
concerning his people and the very end
of time. And then in verse two it says
he had his hand uh in his hand a little
book that was open. This is the book of
Daniel that was once sealed. It's now
opened. When Daniel was given the
prophecies, he didn't understand the
last bit, the last portions of those
prophecies. they pertain to the the
people in the end of time, the 2300 day
prophecy specifically. And so Daniel is
told to seal those up until the time of
the end. And so now the book is open.
When it's opened, Daniel actually hears
the sound of seven thunders. And that
message is given to him and he's about
to write it out. And then a voice says,
"Don't write it." The voice then tells
him to go and eat the little book.
rather than writing out the message of
the seven thunders, go to the book of
Daniel because that's where the message
of the seven thunders is. And so John is
giving us a uh an example uh an
illustration of what we are supposed to
do. And the Millerites uh movement, the
Millerite movement is based on this
experience in Revelation 10. They went
to the book of Daniel. They ate the book
of Daniel and they began to understand
this message that is entitled or
described as the seven thunders in
Revelation chapter 10. Seven represent
perfect, complete, finished thunder
represents the voice of God. And so this
message is actually pointing us to the
very center of the 2300 day prophecy.
It's pointing us to Daniel chapter 9 and
verse 24. And this points to the work of
Jesus Christ, the perfect and complete
work of Jesus Christ, the voice of God
uh declaring the accomplished work of
Jesus Christ in our salvation. And we
see it here in Revelation in Daniel
chapter 9:4 where it says, "Seven weeks
were determined upon thy people and upon
thy holy city to one, finish
transgression. Two, make an end of sins.
Three, make it uh reconciliation for
iniquity. Four, bring in everlasting
righteousness. Five, seal up the vision.
Six, seal up the prophecy. And seven,
anoint the most holy." There are your
seven thunders. God's complete and
perfect message of salvation, new
covenant experience in Jesus Christ
accomplished in him and to be carried as
a message to all the world in these last
days.
>> Amen.
>> Beautiful.
>> Great, great answer there. Derell, your
first question. If God never attempts,
sorry, if God never tempts anyone and
sacrifice is not acceptable to him, how
should we understand Genesis 22 verse1
in the light of James 1:13-16?
And this is from Anthony in Canada.
>> Thanks for that question, Anthony. And
if I understand you correctly, what
you're asking is if human sacrifice is a
sin and God tempts no one, how could he
ask Abraham to sacrifice his own son?
And that's a really good question and I
understand that on the surface it can
look like God is contradicting his own
character because in Genesis 22 in the
King James version it says God did tempt
Abraham. But in the original Hebrew, the
word means to test or to prove, not to
lure someone into doing evil. And so,
Genesis 22 really means God tested
Abraham. And that changes everything.
You see, God wasn't trying to make
Abraham sin. He was proving or testing
the character and faith of Abraham. And
I want to make it abundantly clear that
it was never the purpose of God to cause
Abraham to sacrifice his son at any
point. And that's why the moment Abraham
showed he was willing to trust
completely, God stopped him, saying, "Do
not lay your hand on the lad, for now I
know that you fear God." In other words,
now I know that you have faith. And so,
the real test wasn't about whether or
not Abraham would kill Isaac. It was
about whether or not Abraham would trust
God even when it didn't make sense to
him. God tests faith, but he doesn't
tempt people to do evil. And then James
1:13, which you mentioned, helps us to
understand this point perfectly where it
says, "Let no one say when he is
tempted, I am tempted by God. For God
cannot be tempted with evil, nor does he
tempt anyone." So God never tempts us to
anyone to do sin. The devil tempts to
destroy, but God tests to strengthen.
And we actually see the same pattern
exhibited in other Bible stories. For
instance, when the Canaanite woman in
Matthew 15 asked Jesus to heal her
daughter, Jesus responses to her could
have seemed harsh, but he was trying to
draw out her great faith. And then when
she persisted, Jesus proceeded to bless
her and heal her daughter as he had
intended to from the very beginning. And
then when Peter in vision saw unclean
animals and heard a voice say, "Kill and
eat." That was also a test. Peter obeyed
God's leading to visit Cornelius. And
then he finally understood what the
vision actually meant, which was that
God accepts people from every nation,
whether they're Jew or Gentile. And so
Abraham was never meant to kill his son.
The woman was never meant to stop asking
Jesus for help. And Peter was never
meant to eat those unclean animals. Each
faced a test of faith. And when they
trusted God through the confusion, he
revealed his true purposes to them. So
God never tempts anyone to do evil
again. He tests to grow our faith and to
show us his will. And when life's uh
when life feels confusing, our part is
to keep trusting God no matter what.
Because on the other side of the test,
there's always a clearer view of his
love if we're patient and we wait for
it.
>> Amen. Wonderful answer.
>> Shelley, this is your first question.
>> Okay.
>> If a husband is unfaithful, but his wife
forgives him, should he still be
rebaptized? And this is from Pam in
Pennsylvania. Pam, this is a question
that depends on his spiritual state,
whether or not he'd actually turned away
from faith or if he just had a moral
failure. Rebaptism is necessary only if
he willfully
broke faith with Christ. Basically
saying he's turned away from his
lordship. Um, if a husband's fall was a
moral failure, a temporary lapse into
sin and craziness, and it is followed by
genuine repentance, it is followed by
acknowledging and confessing his sin
before God as and seeking God's
forgiveness as well as his wives. Then
scripture teaches that restoration comes
through that confession and repentance
rather than rebaptism. Let me give you
the references. First John 1:9, if we
confess our sins, he is faithful and
just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us of all unrighteousness.
Galatians 6:1 says, "Brethren, if a man
is overtaken in any trespass, you who
are spiritual, restore such a one in a
spirit of gentleness." Now, if the
husband's sin reflected apostasy, in
other words, if he basically turned his
back on Christ for a while and he was
living a life of unrepentant sin,
rebaptism would definitely be fitting as
a public witness, a a testimony of
renewed faith and commitment. Acts 3:19
says, "Therefore, repent." And to repent
means you're going this direction and
you turn all the way around to the other
direction and be converted, be brought
to spiritual life that your sins may be
blotted out. Either case, whether this
was a moral failure or really
apostrophe,
restoration,
relationship with God requires a
personal repentance. Even if the wife
forgives him, that does not remove his
need for spiritual reconciliation with
God.
I like what David said in Psalm 51:4.
He was guilty of murder and adultery.
And what did he say? Against you and you
only have I sinned and done this in your
sight. He's praying to God. And then in
verse 12 of Psalm 51, he says, "Restore
to me the joy of your salvation and
uphold me by your generous spirit." So
in all cases, focus is on genuine
repentance, renewal of faith, and
restoration of relationship
with God and with the spouse. I would go
so far as to say when someone has
committed adultery, they have broken the
marriage covenant, might be a good idea
to repeat your vows.
>> Amen. Thank you, James. Your second
question. Can you please explain the
three angels messages? Some people are
saying this is not true. This is from
Dvita in New York.
>> Thank you, Dvita. Great question. It is
true actually. The three angels messages
are found in Revelation 14 6-12. And
they take up a period of history from
1844. Well, 1840 uh to 44 all the way
down to the very end of time. The first
angel's message, Revelation 14 6 and 7
uh pinpoints the hour of God's judgment
which we know began in 1844. It
introduces the everlasting gospel which
I believe uh is an umbrella over the
entire three angels messages. Everything
in the messages has to be understood in
the context of the everlasting gospel.
So fear God, give glory to him for the
hour of his judgment is come and worship
him that made heaven and earth and the
seas of the fountains of waters is the
first angel's message. That message is
encapsulated in the everlasting gospel
which also brings us to the second
angel's message in Revelation chapter 14
beginning here with verse 8 is the fall
of Babylon. And we see that fall of
Babylon taking place in a spiritual
sense and in a literal sense. The
spiritual fall took place just after the
first angel's message was given in the
1840 to 1844 period when the Protestant
churches by and large rejected the
message and took a spiritual fall. The
literal fall is going to take place
according to Revelation 18 at the very
end of the third angel's message
sometime well from that period all the
way to the ever end of time but sometime
before us when there's a final mark of
the beast test that's outlined in the
third angel's message. The third angel's
message warns us not to worship the
beast or his image or his mark or uh the
number of his name. That message points
in verse 12 to a people who keep the
commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus. The commandments of God, of
course, obedience to God's moral law,
his ten commandments, which were never
nailed to the cross, but have been
promised be put in our hearts according
to the new covenant in Hebrews chap 8
6-12 and Hebrews chap 10 16 and 17. And
that new covenant promise is going to be
fulfilled in a people who hold on to the
faith of Jesus. That is the faith that
Jesus has in us that produces our faith
in him. He's the author and the finisher
of our faith. So the first angel's
message begins with this proclamation of
this everlasting gospel. To fear God in
the context of the everlasting gospel is
to trust in his mercy. To give glory to
him is to trust in his righteousness and
not to boast in our own righteousness.
Ephesians 2 says in verse 8, "For by
grace you have been saved through faith.
And that is the gift of God, not of
works, lest any man should boast or
glory." So to give glory to God is to
know that we're saved by faith by grace
through faith. And then it says that we
are to prepare for the hour of his
judgment. That's an hour when we are
vindicated. The saints of God are
vindicated according to uh Daniel
chapter 7 by the righteousness of Jesus
Christ. And that vindication
comes as we put our complete weight of
trust, the complete merit for our
salvation in the doing and the dying of
Jesus Christ. His perfect life, his peny
satisfying death becomes a gift to us
and it produces in us a people who
eventually keep the commandments of God
while they keep the faith of Jesus.
Babylon is confusion and confusion about
salvation, about the everlasting gospel,
about the new covenant, about the
worship of God. All of that falls when
the everlasting gospel is preached. So
the gospel produces the fall, the
spiritual fall and eventually the
literal fall of confusion about God. And
of course, the central issue in all of
this is the mark of the beast, which is
contrary to or the opposite of the call
to worship God who made heaven and earth
and the seas and the fountains of
waters. Now, that call to worship is a
direct quotation from the fourth
commandment, the 7th day Sabbath. The
Lord of the Sabbath is Jesus Christ. And
that of course takes us back Exodus
20:es 8-11 take us back to Genesis
chapter 2:es 1-3. and the fact that the
the Sabbath was ordained, set aside,
blessed and given to mankind at
creation. So it reminds us, the three
angels messages reminds us that God is
our creator, that we are to worship him,
that we are not to compromise faith,
that Babylon confusion about God is to
fall, and that we are to keep his
commandments while we keep a hold of the
faith of Jesus.
>> Very good.
>> Amen.
>> Derail, your second question. Could you
please explain John 20:es 22 and 23? If
you forgive anyone's sin, their sins are
forgiven. And this is from Zadeie in
Connecticut.
>> Thank you, Zadeie, for your question.
And at first glance, it does seem like
Jesus is giving, it almost sounds like
Jesus is giving human beings the same
power that belongs to God alone, the
power to forgive sins. So, what does
Jesus really mean by uh uh this passage?
Uh let's look at what the Bible says. Uh
and one of the greatest examples of what
forgiveness is supposed to look like is
found in 1 John 1:9
where it says, "If we confess our sins,
he is faithful and just to forgive us
our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness." And that verse shows
us how God forgives sin. When someone
comes to God in sincere confession,
trusting him fully, God promises
cleansing and pardon. And how does he
accomplish this? First John 1:7 says
that the blood of Jesus Christ his son
cleanses us from all sin. So forgiveness
flows only from one source, from God
himself through the blood of Christ his
son. Human beings have no power to
forgive sin in that divine sense. And
when a sinner confesses to God and they
turn away from sin and believe in
Christ's power to forgive, Romans 3:es
25 and 26 are fulfilled which say for
God presented Jesus as the sacrifice for
sin. People are made right with God when
they believe that Jesus sacrificed his
life shedding his blood. So being
forgiven and made right with God are
God's work to accomplish not our own.
And uh what what is meant by John
chapter 20 verses 22 and 23 which you
mentioned where it says if you forgive
anyone's sins they are forgiven. This
verse isn't saying that the church or
its leaders can forgive sins in the
sense uh that God does. Rather, Jesus
was giving his followers the authority
to proclaim God's forgiveness or to
declare on heaven's behalf what God has
already promised in his word. Here's how
it works. When someone sincerely
confesses their sins and puts their
trust in Jesus, the church through its
ministers and fellow believers has
heaven's authorities to say, "Brother or
sister, based on God's promises, your
sins are forgiven."
It's not human power. It's not uh human
power to forgive sins. It's divine
assurance that is being conveyed in that
passage in John chap 20 22 and 20 uh and
23. So confession is made to God.
Forgiveness comes from God. And the
church's role is to affirm what God has
already done for the repentant sinner.
And the opposite is also true. If
someone refuses to repent, the church
can only declare what God's word has
already said. That sins unconfessed and
unforgaken remain unforgiven.
So whether it be the forgiveness of sins
or the condemnation of the unrepentant,
both are the works of God. Yet through
the authority invested in his church,
these divine results are to be affirmed
by the church, not based on human
opinion or judgment, but solely based
upon what God has spoken in his word. So
in short, forgiveness is from God alone,
and the church's sacred duty is to
proclaim that forgiveness to those who
truly repent and believe in Christ.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Shelley, your second uh question.
>> Did God harden Pharaoh's heart?
>> And this is just a message that came in.
A question that came in.
>> Okay. So, what we want to do is think
about Exodus 9:16. What was the purpose
of God's plague? The plagues that God
sent, God told Moses that he was going
to show his power that his name might be
declared in all the earth. So God sent
plagues on Egypt to reveal his power,
his justice, and his mercy to give Egypt
the opportunity to repent. Pharaoh first
hardened his own heart. He repeatedly
chose to resist God. Every time Moses
brought him a message from God, he was
like, "Who is God that I should listen
to him?" He hardened his heart through
inner rebellion. And actually, Exodus
8:15,
Exodus 8:32,
and Exodus 9:34 all state Pharaoh
hardened his heart. Every plague was an
appeal to Pharaoh's conscience. God was
demonstrating his sovereignty over those
false Egyptian gods. And each time that
Pharaoh resisted, his will grew more
stubborn until his heart was spiritually
hardened beyond recovery. You know that
is the cumulative effect. the result of
repeated refusal to surrender to God.
Actually, Proverbs 29:1 says, "He who is
often rebuked and hardens his neck will
suddenly be destroyed and that without
remedy." So afterward, God allowed
Pharaoh's hardness of heart to become
fixed. Exodus 9:12 finally says, "And
the Lord hardened the heart of Pharaoh."
God did not arbitrarily harden Pharaoh's
heart. Basically, what he was doing,
this wasn't against Pharaoh's will
because God never coerces us. God gave
us free will. He never coerces us. But
freedom of choice brings moral
responsibility and consequences. And God
permitted what Pharaoh had already
chosen. He allowed Pharaoh's chosen
attitude of pride and rebellion to
solidify after many chances of trying to
reach him. So it's interesting the
manifestation of God's power that
hardened Pharaoh's heart softened many
of the Egyptians hearts.
And you know, think about this. The same
sun that hardens clay, softens wax.
Genesis 6:3, God said, "My spirit shall
not always strive with man." The same
spirit that melts one heart can harden
another. Isn't that interesting? Not
because God changes, but because human
response
determines the effect. So the story of
Pharaoh is a solemn warning to us that
continued rejection of truth can make
repentance increasingly difficult.
>> Amen. Thank you. Good answer, Shelley.
Just want to remind you just how to
submit your questions to here at 3ABN is
if you want to text those questions in
6182283975.
If you'd like to email them,
bibleqa3abn.tv
and if you'd like to use Instagram, 3ABN
official. So that's the three ways that
you can get your questions to us. James,
your third question. What was the
purpose and symbolism of the four living
creatures in Revelation 4:7,
also mentioned in Ezekiel? And this is
from Marlene.
Thank you Marlene for that question. You
know regarding the four beasts or four
living creatures uh these creatures are
angels. Uh we see that in Ezekiel uh as
you mentioned is there in Ezekiel 1 and
chapter 10 also in Isaiah chapter 6 1-7
as well as Revelation 1 uh 4 1-9. So the
the features of these creatures which
you asked about you know they're like a
man, they're like a lion, they're like
an eagle, they're like an ox. They
represent the work of angels on planet
Earth. Now, here's some Bible verses
that we can look at to support this
understanding. First of all, we're told
in Hebrews 13:2, "Be not uh forgetful to
entertain strangers, for thereby some
have entertained angels unawares."
Right? So, angels
uh sometimes come in the form of men.
So, these living creatures are like a
man in that they appear on earth as men
from time to time. Lion. Now, a lion in
the Bible represents the authority and
the power of uh Jesus Christ. He is the
lion of the tribe of Judah. And when
angels come, they're given that kingly
authority and power, the kingly
authority of power of God uh on planet
Earth. We see that for example in
Matthew 28:es 2-4 when this angel comes
as a great earthquake. The angel of the
Lord descends from heaven and he rolls
back uh the stone from the door and he
sat upon it and his countenance is like
lightning. His raignment is white as
snow and for fear of him the keepers uh
of the tomb there the Roman soldiers uh
became dead man men. So the lion would
represent the power and the authority of
heaven. The man would represent the fact
that angels come in the appearance of
men. An ox would represent the
self-sacrificing
labor that angels perform for humanity.
In Hebrews chapter 2:14,
uh it talks about how these angels are
all ministering spirits sent forth to
minister to those of us who shall be
heirs of salvation. And then lastly, we
have the eagle. The eagle would
represent uh the flight of the angels.
You know, eagles are known for their
flight, their swift flight, their strong
wings. And in Daniel chapter 9 21,
Daniel was praying to God and Gabriel
comes. The angel comes to answer his
prayer and he says, "I was sent to fly
swiftly to you." So God has given these
angels the ability to fly quickly to our
aid. Now the number four, the four
living creatures, the number four
represents the four directions of the
compass. You've got north,sou, east, and
west. And this suggests according to for
example Revelation 7 1-3 that the angels
that minister to us are surrounding the
whole earth. They're north, south, east,
and west. They're all encompassing,
right? Every one of us has a guardian
angel. So these four living creatures
represent the tireless ministry of God's
heavenly angels, their power, their
authority, their uh manifestation in
human form. And they come to work to
minister uh for humanity. They come to
make us help us to be heirs of
salvation.
>> Great, great uh great answer there,
Darell. Number three, are we going to
have time alone with Jesus in heaven?
From what I read, 144,000 follow him
wherever he goes. And this is from
Missy.
>> Missy, that's a very heartfelt question.
Will Christ have time for me or for you
personally individually in his kingdom?
And I believe we can start in Matthew
chapter 6 verse 6 where it says
something special. It says, "But you
when you pray, go into your room and
when you have shut your door, pray to
your father who is in see in the secret
place and your father who sees in secret
will reward you openly." So what does
this have to do with this? Well, what is
the purpose of this instruction? Or at
least in part? Jesus said, "When you
pray, go into your room and shut the
door and then pray to your father." This
describes intimate personal
communication with God. And from this
passage, we see that God desires not
only group worship and fellowship, but
one onone communion with each of his
children.
Notice that the verse says, "Your father
who sees in secret." That means it's
just between you and God. Between me and
God.
And it's always been Jesus' habit to do
this both before his incarnation and
during his earthly life to spend
personal private time with his
followers. In Genesis 18, the
pre-incarnate Christ appeared to Abraham
with two angels. And afterward he spoke
face tof face with Abraham as he
interceded for Sodom and Gomorrah. And
then later in his earthly ministry we
see the same pattern of personal
attention being given. The woman at the
well met privately with Jesus and spoke
with him. Nicodemus came to him
privately by night to have a
conversation with him. Zakius was told
personally today I must stay at your
house by Jesus. And after his
resurrection, Jesus spoke privately to
Peter on a beach. And John was alone on
Patmos when Jesus appeared to him in
vision. Even at the very beginning of
Earth's history, Jesus walked and talked
with Adam and Eve in the Garden of Eden
face to face in perfect communion.
And even when surrounded by great
multitudes, Jesus never lost sight of
the individual. Matthew 15:30 says,
"Then then great multitudes came to
Jesus, having with them the lame, blind,
mute, maimed, and many others, and they
laid them down at Jesus' feet, and he
healed them." Notice, though the crowds
were vast, each person was brought
individually to Jesus, and he healed
them one by one. His pattern was
consistent. He mingled among the
multitudes, but he met people
personally, intimately, individually.
And Revelation tells us, as you said,
that the saved will be made up of
actually not just 144,000, but it it
says that there will be a great
multitude which no man could number
according to Revelation 7:9.
Yet the same God who counts the stars,
who numbers the hairs of our heads, who
calls each of us by name, will never be
too busy to spend time alone with any of
us. And throughout the ceaseless ages of
eternity, we will worship together as
one great family. Yet, we will each have
our own private moments with Jesus.
moments where he looks into our eyes,
calls us by name, and reminds us that
with his with his everlasting love, he
gave himself for us personally.
>> Amen. That's very good. Very good.
Shelley, your third question. When God
clothed Adam and Eve, did they repent of
their wrongs? In scripture, Adam blames
God and then the blame game continues.
Why did Adam and Eve then receive animal
skins as coverings? Was the nakedness of
Adam and Eve literal? And this is from
two people that sent in individual
questions. This is from Tony in Canada
and Walter in Kenya.
>> Well, Tony and Walter, these are
wonderful questions. And let me just
begin by saying yes, the uh nakedness of
Adam and Eve was literal and we'll see
in a moment. It also became spiritual.
Um before sin, they were physically
uncovered
with or they weren't covered with
anything physical, but they were clothed
with God's robe of light as a visible
sign of his righteousness and their
perfect harmony with him. In Genesis
2:25, it says, "They both were naked,
the man and his wife, and they were not
ashamed."
When they disobeyed,
God removed that robe of light. It
disappeared. And then they recognized
not just their spiritual loss, their
spiritual covering, but they recognized
their physical nakedness. In Genesis 3:7
says, "The eyes of both of them were
opened to the knowledge of good and evil
is what I would uh respond." And uh it
says they knew that they were naked. So
then we see in Genesis 3:9 that God
comes and asks, "Where are you?" That he
they're used to walking with him in the
garden. God isn't searching for
information. And he's giving them an
opportunity to confess and repent. And
sadly, Adam and Eve do what most of us
do nowadays. They blameshifted
and tried to justify their own actions.
Genesis 3:12,
Adam says [clears throat] to the Lord,
"The woman you gave me
that you're the reason, Lord, the woman
you gave me to be with me, she gave me
of the tree and I ate." It's kind of
sound like he's blame shifting the blame
on God. In Genesis 3:13,
what does Eve say? The serpent deceived
me and I ate. So there was truth in
that. She was deceived. So here's what I
think. Even though their repentance was
incomplete,
God responded to them with grace. In the
garden, we see the first substitutionary
sacrifice that made that pointed
toward the lamb of God, Jesus Christ. It
says Genesis 3:21, "For Adam and his
wife, the Lord made tunics of skin and
clothed them." An innocent life had to
be taken for their covering symbolizing
Christ's future action. You know, Adam
and Eve had those fig leaves aprons that
they tried to make
that represented human effort. Never
going to never going to crack it for
salvation. But God's covering
represented divine righteousness. So the
love of God covered their shame even
while their hearts were still learning
repentance. His grace always reaches us
before we reach him. In Romans 2:4 it
says it is the goodness of God that
leads us to repentance.
>> Amen. Amen. Good. James, your fourth
question.
Is the 144,000 literal or symbolic? My
husband disagrees with the concept of
the 144,000 being saved and refuses to
follow the 7th Adventist beliefs. He
cannot believe that out of 7 billion
people in the world, only that number
will be saved, that 144,000.
And this is from Aedro in Georgia.
Well, and I really am thankful that you
asked this question because if it is
something that is hindering your husband
from accepting the Seventh Day Adventist
beliefs, I'm hoping that we can clear it
up and that a way can be made for him to
step into uh the church. Uh it is
crystal clear from the Bible that the
144,000 is not a literal number. And we
know this for several reasons, but let
me just say on the onset that there are
at least four or five different
interpretations of the 144,000 in the
Seventh Day Adventist Church. It is not
a testing issue and we do not believe
that the idea that it is literal or
symbolic is something that should hinder
people from being saved or accepting the
message. However, it's very obvious from
this question that for some people this
is going to hinder them from accepting
Adventism as is the case in your
situation. So, let me just share with
you in re Revelation chapter 7, we have
the 144,000 identified. And in
Revelation chapter 14, they're
identified. These are the two places in
the whole Bible where they're
identified. Revelation 15 suggests that
it's talking about the 144,000 who sing
the song of Moses and the lamb. All of
these verses are quite symbolic. In
Revelation 7, you have the 12 tribes of
Israel described as those that are
sealed, 144,000. Well, that means that
only literal Israelites can be saved if
we take that literally. You can't allow
a literal number to be immersed in
symbolic uh representations. In other
words, if we're going to make that
number literal, we have to make the
tribes literal also, and they're not.
And then in Revelation chapter 14, you
have the description of the 144,000 as
in Revelation 14:4 as being women who
are not defiled with virgins. So the
summation summary you would come to here
is that the 144,000
are literal male Jewish virgins who have
never slept with a woman. And now you're
limiting it even more. If you're going
to be literal, you have to be
consistent. And some of our evangelical
friends are consistent. They believe
that this is talking about literal male
Israelites that are going to come to
Christ during the tribulation period
after the church has been raptured out.
We don't believe that. We believe all of
these symbols represent God's people.
First fruits, those who are born again
according to James chapter 1. Virgins,
those who are not corrupted with other
faiths according to second Corinthians
chapter 11. Following the lamb wherever
he goes. The lamb represents Jesus who
was crucified for us our savior. The
144,000 is symbolic in Revelation 21
where the bride is described or we
should say the new Jerusalem city. There
are 12 gates with the name of the 12
tribes and there are 12 foundations with
the name of the 12 apostles. 12* 12 is
144. A thousand is the largest number
used in the Bible. When God wants to get
big, he'll say a thousand times 10
thousands and thousands of thousands. So
when you look in Revelation 7, you first
have this vision that John hears. He
doesn't see the sealing of God's people.
He hears the sealing of God's people.
And it's verse four. And I heard the
number of them that were sealed. In
verse nine, after this I beheld and lo,
I he looks and there's a great multitude
that no man can number. What John first
hears, he then sees. This is a pattern
in the book of Revelation. We see it in
Revelation 1, for example, where God
John hears the voice of a trumpet. When
he turns around, he sees Jesus Christ.
John hears those that are sealed,
144,000, symbolic number, and then he
sees a great multitude that no one can
number. So please assure your husband
that the great multitude that no one can
number is the actual picture of the
redeemed from every nation, kindred,
tongue, and people. That means God is
generous in the plan of salvation.
There's room enough for heaven in heaven
for everyone who wants to be there.
>> Amen. Very, very good. Derell, your
fourth question. In the book of Job,
Satan needed permission from God to
cause Job bodily grief, emotional grief,
and spiritual suffering. Does that rule
still apply today for the humans who are
going through those very things? And
this is from Mike in Michigan.
>> Mike, I I want you to listen to these
words in Psalm 91:es 2 and 4. Uh 2:4
says, "This I declare about the Lord. He
alone is my refuge, my place of safety.
He is my God and I trust him. For he
will rescue you from every trap and
protect you from deadly disease. He will
cover you with his feathers. He will
shelter you with his wings. His faithful
promises are your armor and protection.
This passage shows that when we place
ourselves in the protective hands of
God, Satan cannot reach us unless God
allows it. If the enemy were given full
freedom to tempt, to harm, to destroy,
humanity wouldn't survive a single day.
But we are preserved by God's mercies.
As the prophet Jeremiah wrote in
Lamentations 3:es 22 and 23, "Through
the Lord's mercies we are not consumed
because his compassions fail not. They
are new every morning. Great is his
faithfulness."
Even after Job's time, scripture
continues to pull back the curtain and
show us this same heaven heavenly
reality. In Zechariah 3:es 1 and 2, the
prophet saw a vision of Joshua the high
priest standing before the angel of the
Lord with Satan at his right hand to
accuse him. But get this, the Lord said,
"The Lord rebuke you, Satan. The Lord
who has chosen Jerusalem rebuke you. Is
not is this not a brand plucked from the
fire?" Speaking of Joshua. So in that
moment, God himself defended his servant
against the accusations of the enemy
just as he defends all who place their
trust in him. So even when Jesus faced
temptation in the wilderness, scripture
says in Matthew 4:1, "Then Jesus was led
up of the spirit into the wilderness to
be tempted of the devil." So even there
it was the spirit who permitted the
encounter. Satan's access to Christ on
earth and to all of his followers is
always limited and supervised by God's
great wisdom. And when permission is
given, it is only for our ultimate good
and for God's greater purposes. We see
this again when Jesus cast out demons in
Matthew chapter 8. In verse 31 and 32 it
says, "So the demons begged him, saying,
if you cast us out, permit us to go away
into the herd of swine." And so Jesus
said to them, "Go." So even the demons
needed permission to act, every step
they take, every boundary they they
cross is under the authority of Christ
to say yes or no. So I believe in the
heart of your question is a deeper one.
Why does God allow Satan, demons, and
even people to cause human suffering?
And one answer is that God is allowing
the full results of sin to be revealed
so that when he finally brings sin,
suffering, and Satan to a complete and
fi final end, the universe will never
question his justice and love again. As
Paul reminds us in 2 Corinthians 4:17,
for our light affliction, which is but
for a moment, is working for us a far
more exceeding and eternal weight of
glory. So, let's look forward to that.
>> Amen.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> Excellent answer,
>> Shellyley. Your fourth question. Are we
given the Holy Spirit from birth or do
we have to ask for the Holy Spirit? And
this is from John in Ohio. John, this is
such an important question and I'm so
glad that you asked it because everyone
needs to know the answer to this. The
Bible teaches that the Holy Spirit is
not automatically given at birth. Every
person is born with a Godgiven
conscience and we have the ability to
respond to the Holy Spirit's convicting
influence. He's always drawing trying to
draw men toward God even before they
know Christ. John 16:8 says Jesus is
speaking of the spirit when he has come.
He will convict the world of sin, of
righteousness and judgment. So the Holy
Spirit convicts, he calls, he woos, but
he never forces himself upon us. His
inddwelling presence comes only when we
develop a personal relationship with
Jesus Christ. When we enter into
covenant with Christ, accepting him as
both our savior and our Lord and we're
converted, we repent, we're converted,
we're born again by the spirit as a
child of God. And that's when this Holy
Spirit comes to live in us, to comfort
us, guide us, and empower us. Acts 2:38
and 39, Peter is speaking at Pentecost.
He says to the crowd, "Repent and be
baptized in the name of Jesus Christ for
the remission of sins, and you shall
receive the gift of the Holy Spirit. For
the promises to you and to your children
and to who all who are a far off as many
as the Lord our God will call. Galatians
4:6 Paul says because you are sons. You
have been born again adopted by God into
his family. He says, "God has sent forth
his spirit of his son into your hearts
by whom we cry out, aba, father,
papa, god." Ephesians 3:16 and1 17 Paul
says that according to the riches of his
glory. God grants us to be strengthened
with might through his spirit in our
inner man so that Christ may dwell in
our hearts by faith and we can be rooted
and grounded in his love. So while the
spirit's influencing
begins before conversion, the infilling,
his indwelling living in us is only as
we yield our hearts to God. And let me
tell you something, it's not a one-time
experience. This is a dayby-day
surrendering. Believers are called to
ask continually to be filled with the
Holy Spirit. Jesus said in Luke uh
chapter 11 verses 9 and 10, ask and it
will be given to you. Seek and you will
find. Knock and the door will be open.
In the Greek, these are continuous
linear verbs, continuous action. He's
saying ask and keep on asking.
Seek and keep on seeking. Knock and keep
on knocking. And then in verse 13, he he
explains what we're asking for. He says,
"If you being evil know how to give good
gifts to your children, how much more
will the heavenly father give the Holy
Spirit to those who ask him and keep on
asking." So just as we need daily bread,
we need daily presence and renewal of
the Holy Spirit. We're not born
possessing the Holy Spirit, but from
birth, he [snorts] is trying to draw us
to God. When we open our hearts to
Christ and we accept him as Christ as
savior and lord, he will be happy to
fill us with his spirit.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Why don't we uh Thank y'all. Thank you
so much. Why don't we just take a short
break and then we'll come back and we'll
have additional comments and then we'll
just uh have a prayer.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy [music] word to shed
light on those texts that seem difficult
to understand. To have your questions
answered on [music] a future program,
just email them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv. [music]
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975. [music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live. And then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
Welcome back. Okay. Do we have any
additional comments?
>> Yeah, I quickly wanted to make a comment
about being filled with the Holy Spirit
at birth. There are instances where that
has happened. We think of Luke 1:15
where John the Baptist was filled with
the Holy Spirit in the womb. But that's
a rare occasion. And I just want to say
in reference to when God permits us to
be tested, we can always remember James
1:es 2 to uh 4 which say my brethren
count it all joy when you fall into
various trials knowing that the testing
of your faith produces patience but let
patience have its perfect work that you
may be perfect and complete lacking
nothing.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. James,
>> and just a just a quick reference to the
144,000. And if you go to
3ABMBbibleansers.com,
that's 3ABMBbibleansers.com,
you're going to find a study on the
144,000. You can also uh email me and I
can send you a copy of this book uh in a
digital format, not a hard copy format,
and it is an exhaustive study on the
144,000. So, if you'd like more
information, just go to 3ABNBansers.com
or email me at james.rapertyabn.org.
Amen.
>> And I want to make one more comment. You
know, when we were talking about Pharaoh
hardening his heart against God,
this is such a warning to us. We have to
remember that when we resist God's
divine appeals. This can lead to
spiritual callousness. God is still
speaking today through his word and his
spirit. He gently calls us to yield our
hearts to him. But every time we resist
conviction, our hearts grow a little
harder. Each time that we surrender, he
softens us and he gets us to where we
can be more receptive to the sound of
his voice. Hebrews 3:15 is what I want
to leave you with. It's so important
today. If you will hear his voice, do
not harden your heart. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Anyone else have anything?
Let's just have a closing prayer.
Father, we thank you for this wonderful
study. We ask Lord that you will be with
each one of us, all those that are
watching, all those Lord that need to
hear your voice. We [music] just lift
this time up to you. And we ask this in
the name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Have a wonderful day. God bless.
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.